[Applaudissements]
2012 en syrie qui a commencé
pacifiquement avec le printemps arabe se
transforme t en guerre civile
les morts se multiplient c'est le début
de l'exode
parmi ce chaos deux américain pris en
otage par les forces d'al qaïda en série
matthew schryer prisonnier pendant sept
mois
théo pas de noces passera 22 mois de sa
vie en captivité
les deux sont déplacés d'une prison à
l'autre affamés battus et torturés
deux enjeux du rj due forme
15-14 plus dans une de ces prisons ils
seront interrogés par des hommes masqués
et extorqué non plus pas voir ce visage
les qualités que job que je repérais
c'était leur accent ils parlent se
reconnaître l'accent québécois au magnum
en syrie se trouve un groupe de jeunes
du québec partis combattre
bachar al assad il était masqué comment
peut-on identifier quelqu'un sous un
masque
ça pourrait être n'importe qui
cet accent québécois rrq pourrait-il
être associé à l'un d'entre eux c'est
pas correct que n'importe qui puisse
partir [ __ ] le bordel dans un autre
pays et revenir vivre en paix ici sont
peu ou aucun prix au coeur de l'histoire
des secrets bien gardés
des questions sans réponses et des
otages à bout de patience
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
théo pas de noces un journaliste pigiste
se retrouve à la frontière entre la
turquie et la syrie
ébranlé par les mort et la souffrance il
est convaincu que celle réussi à
franchir la frontière
il pourrait faire une différence je
cherche des histoires je cherche des
importants jaffer je juge de petite
enquête
théo avait déjà vécu au moyen orient
plus précisément au yémen en 2004 où il
a écrit le livre hommes de carmaux slam
sur la croissance de l'extrémisme
musulman
il a par la suite passé deux ans en
syrie et a continué ses études de la
langue arabe et de l'islam
je pensais que quand j'écrivais sur les
problèmes en syrie que j'arrivais à
comprendre mieux comprendre et mieux
expliquer les patients qui circulent en
syrie je me suis dit y'a que moi qui
puisse faire ce travail j'étais un peu
égoïste est d'accord mais malgré son
expérience et tous ses efforts la
frontière demeure est franchissable
trois portes d'entrée dans cette région
il ya un terreau accueil accueil à
bokassa propose d'entrer en syrie
ils m'ont refusé à chaque porte
plusieurs fois parce qu'il vaut et
américains américains ils m'ont refusé
pendant que théo est bloqué à la
frontière syrienne à dix mille
kilomètres plus à l'ouest
une dizaine de jeunes hommes
s'entraînent dans un centre de tir dans
la région de montréal
certains s'exerce deux ou trois fois par
semaine pendant des mois
plusieurs d'entre eux se sont converties
à l'islam
ça s'est fait tranquillement elle s'est
convertie sans qu'on sache quand on l'a
appris nous c'était déjà fait pb ce sens
a été graduelle dans le fond on a vu le
cheminement petit à petit se faire
vraiment se radicaliser vraiment devenir
de plus en plus obtus dans ses opinions
cet individu connaît bien le des jeunes
pour protéger sa relation avec lui
il a exigé l'anonymat selon des témoins
les jeunes apportent avec eux deux armes
dont une imitation de carabine
semi-automatique soviétique communément
appelée sks une arme similaire à celle
utilisée par les rebelles en syrie les
jeunes arrivent toujours avec cinq
balles et tirs chacun leur tour lui
l'entraînement le tir à la carabine y
voit le seul dans le fond que que
c'était légal
c'était pas interdit de le faire puisque
tout le monde peut le faire puisque non
pour lui il voyait pas de mal à ça
les jeunes vont au centre de tir à
l'invitation de trois hommes wassim boga
doudou à 20 ans a des origines
algériennes et entraîneur dans un james
il détient des permis pour tirer il
avait donc le droit d'amener des amis
s'exercer avec lui au centre de tir
le deuxième à détenir un permis est un
des jeunes de 24 ans qui a étudié en
médecine et possède une double
citoyenneté tunisienne et canadiennes
nous avons brouiller son visage ainsi
que celui de tous ceux qui sont toujours
sous enquête et qui vivent encore au
québec
les deux hommes paient pour
l'entraînement du groupe le troisième
homme et à hexacoeurs étudiants en
pharmacie est d'origine syrienne selon
nos sources de type n'est effectuée dans
la région de lattaquié endroits où des
violences ont éclaté lors du début du
conflit en syrie benoît gagnon est
spécialiste en sécurité et en
antiterrorisme
quand le savent a commencé à commettre
des exactions prend par exemple
chimiques et caetera et beaucoup
beaucoup de matériel qui a été distribué
à travers internet des vidéos carré a
augmenté leurs sentiments de
d'attachement il voyait ça comme des
musulmans qui étaient massacrés qui
étaient tués
et pour lui ça allait contre le principe
de base du slam et y voyait bachar al
assad comme un ennemi de la paix et de
l'islam
au début tout se déroule sans incident
mais les jeunes arrêtent souvent tirés
pour prier et cette pratique religieuse
dérange
la tension entre les employés du centre
et les jeunes atteint son paroxysme
lorsque client aurait entendu une phrase
inquiétante
un jeune aurait dit que c'était
malheureux que les sites ne soient pas
des mécréants
est ce une mauvaise blague les
propriétaires ne prennent aucun risque
et alerte les autorités
l'enquète policière est déclenché
coincés à la frontière to8 cherche
d'autres moyens de traverser en syrie il
prend l'avion vers la jordanie y réussit
enfin à mettre les pieds en sol syrien
c'était vraiment le début des problèmes
graves en syrie a terrassé les magazines
mais revue american mais eux ils m'ont
refusé gt1 syrie je leur ai dit je suis
là j'ai plein de reportages d'affaires
il voulait pas avoir entendre de moi
quoi le journaliste pigiste n'arrive pas
à vendre ses articles aux revues
américaines en avril
théo décide de rentrer chez lui aux
etats unis je vais passer pro semaines
en syrie
j'ai eu aucun succès dans ces trois
semaines je suis entré sans avoir pu
lier aucun article
pendant ce temps au centre de tir les
policiers s'installe et sont présents
lorsque les jeunes s'exercent la grc
mais plusieurs des jeunes sous écoute
électronique
ils surveillent parfois jour et nuit on
voit progrès de l'intérêt quelque part
[Musique]
donc c'est quand même plus haut que la
vaste majorité des opérations qui sont
faibles il y avait des doutes sur ce
qu'il voulait fermer personnes savaient
ce qu'ils voulaient faire non plus ils
savaient pas où ils se rendraient
éventuellement il pensait qu'il s'en
irait combattre en syrie mais c'était
pour claire non plus
quelques semaines plus tard tarek saga
sera le premier à quitter le pays pour
le moyen orient
deux autres vont le suivre en septembre
le jeune de 24 ans et un de ses amis qui
à 19 ans à l'époque rendu aéroports
montréal-trudeau
ils apprennent qu'ils sont sur la liste
leur interdisant de vos lits dans
l'espace aérien américain celui de 24
ans partira une semaine plus tard avec
son passeport tunisien
le jeune 19 ans quitterait le pays de
l'aéroport d'halifax
le no fly list canadien est un peu plus
permis ce qu'on retire
est ce que cette personne l'or
représente un danger imminent pour le
goal tandis que aux états unis si vous
êtes sur la no fly list
prenez pour l'avion lors de son départ
de l'aéroport d'halifax
le jeune de 19 ans apporte dans ses
bagages un viseur et des lunettes de
vision nocturne un dessin assez dur avec
ça c'est quoi
mais on ses clacs pour une utilisation
sur une arme à feu à tout le moins et où
dans un contexte soit de simulation
combo de combos
au mois de novembre 2012 wassim boga
doudou quittera le pays avec un autre
jeune qui était mineur à cette époque il
dit à ses amis que la grc est en train
de ruiner sa vie la grc étaient à ses
trousses parce qu'il possédait des armes
à feu et j'en avais vu avec ses amis
dans un centre de tir en train de
s'exercer avec leurs fusils
il a dit que certains ont eu peur et ont
alerté les policiers mais wassim ne dit
pas tout à son ami en 2011 il a été
accusé de possession d'une arme prohibée
et son procès n'aura jamais lieu parce
qu'il quitte le pays
selon nos sources wassim était connu
comme un fraudeur bien organisée il ne
fait pas ce à aucune accusation arts et
matières wassim a quitté le pays en
catimini
tout comme plusieurs des autres jeunes
ça a été quelque chose s'était préparé
les amis l'ont aidé à se préparer mais
nous on était vraiment dans l'ignorance
la plus totale des jeunes qui ont
fréquenté le centre de thé sign
partiront vers la turquie pendant l'été
et l'automne 2012 deux autres les
suivront en 2013 selon source
il représente la première vague de
jeunes québécois à avoir quitté le
canada pour aller combattre en syrie
ils étaient sous surveillance depuis le
mois de mai il y aurait pu nous
contacter pour nous dire écoutez pensé
partir parce qu on aurait pu faire
quelque chose on se serait pas rendu
leur autrement pendant que les jeunes
préparent leurs débats théo essaie de
retrouver sa vie paisible au vermont je
me sentais que les murs se resserrait
sur moi donc
mais je me suis dit j'ai pas d'autres
possibilités il faut que je fasse ça je
passais tous été en savant que j'allais
en fin d'été j'allais retourner y avait
que ça qui m'intéresse et je n'étais pas
un peu borné d'accord
le 30 septembre 2012 avec en main un
billet aller seulement teopad noces
prend l'avion de montréal vers istanbul
météo ignore que bien des choses ont
changé à la frontière syrienne
les journalistes autrefois et touchable
sont maintenant devenu une monnaie des
changes
[Musique]
le 20 octobre 2012 théo panos se
retrouve à nouveau à la frontière
syrienne
c'est dans la ville d'ataq yard turquie
qui se loue une chambre dans un petit
hôtel ils échangent alors avec des
combattants de l'armée syrienne libre
gimont propose de descendre ont chiffré
à 20 que je me suis dit je vais parler
avec les guérillas mais avec seulement
300 dollars en poche
théo doit faire un choix j'ai trouvé
quelques délinquants dans un autre hôtel
encore moins cher
et eux ils me proposaient de descendre
son pays en quoi que ce soit gratuit de
la remet tait ou par avec eux c'est une
erreur de ma part de penser que je
pouvais faire ça on y connaît en faisant
des petites petites économies débile
comme ça alors que j'aurais dû dépenser
de l'argent pour protéger ma vie
ils dorment une première nuit dans une
maison abandonnée
le lendemain assis par terre rentrer et
de faire une entrevue avec un titre aux
voyageurs la vidéo dérape c'est qu'aux
voyageurs font devenir c'est qu'il n'a
pas afin de 15 minutes
un autre qui n'a peur c'est le vin il a
dit et en laye album il a invité les
autres à venir auprès de moi pour
tabasser un peu avec leurs bottes avec
leurs mains j'ai entendu dire parce que
tu as passé j'ai un autre disait j bale
crouch et ça veut dire amener les
menottes
dans les jours suivants il passera d'un
geôlier à l'autre pour finalement se
retrouver dans les mains de membres
appartenant au front j'habite alnot sera
qui à l'époque faisait partie de la
branche d'al qaida rssi
dabou se transforme en torture
c'était des amateurs mais libre syrienne
au niveau de la torture sens ils savent
pas ce qu'ils font c'est pas c'est pas
un système alors que j'avais tout cela
c'est systématique ce qu'ils font
[Musique]
comme théo la plupart des jeunes
montréalais atterrissent à istanbul
avant de descendre vers la ville
frontière dan takia qu'est ce que vous
savez sur le fait pendant son absence
rien ceci comme une page qui a tourné de
xavi il veut pas en parler du tout vous
a jamais rien dit
non pas du tout pensez-vous qui a
traversé la frontière
moi je pense pas nous mais notre enquête
démontre qu'ils auraient tous
traversants syrie à l'automne 2012
certains ont rejoint un important groupe
rebelle l'armée syrienne libre je pense
qui est parti avec des bonnes intentions
lui vraiment y croyez vraiment les faire
du travail humanitaire
mais moi je pense qui est arrivé là-bas
au pire il ya vraiment vu comment ça se
passait la main puis j'ai peut-être été
désillusionnés par rapport à tout ça
puis je pense qu'il a vraiment réalisé
que ça n'avait rien à voir avec la
religion
les gens qui descendent par exemple
d'aller régions ne peuvent pas pour des
raisons bien personnelles sade volonté
d'aider que le discours peut paraître
très entamée pour prendre les armes
ce soir qu' il ya un peu des deux amouri
pictures si tu es toi à la mi décembre
matusz ou ailleurs arrivent en syrie il
a accepté de raconter son histoire à nos
collègues de la sib ici
jeune photographe à la pige mathiot à
l'eau même espoir que théo réussir à se
faire connaître comme correspondant à
l'étranger
il passe dix huit jours au coeur de la
bataille et prendre des milliers de
photos son voyage est un grand succès
matthew prend le chemin de retour mais à
quelques kilomètres de la frontière
son taxi se fait intercepter je me suis
dit löw convient d'éviter un accident
mais il avait dit ak 47 un gars tout
mais tu meurs on s'est regardé il a
baissé mathieu sur mes yeux et a mis un
fusil sur la dette
[Musique]
matthew est aussi capturés par ja batal
nostra on l'amène à l'hôpital pour
enfants d'alep et on le questionne de
l'autre côté des murs de sa cellule il
entend des prisonniers se faire torturer
il commence à compter les jours une
sorte de mécanisme de survie qui
deviendra une obsession chaque jour je
disais le dot une dizaine de fois 25
février 2013
mais je la répéter tous les jours cette
nouvelle manie lui permet de dire
précisément que trois semaines après son
arrivée il est amené dans une autre
cellule celle de théo panos premier
compagnon en trois mois
théo va vite se rendre compte que la vie
à deux dans une cellule n'est pas de
tout repos
j'étais content mais ça va durer on
s'est disputés plus ou moins tout de
suite sont en débat et c'est un acte
violent tankan s'entendait pas à cause
de sa violence ni tabassé dans la
cellule il se cachait sous les
couvertures toute la journée
examiné mon moral
en janvier 2013 le groupe jabateh nostra
qui détient les deux otages américains
est devenu une force militaire à ne pas
négliger
alors ça et effectivement un gros plus
organisée c'est ça a été vu comme un des
phares de larmes
cette branche al qaïda est reconnu pour
son côté militaire très efficace et
disciplinée mais plus devant des groupes
sont plus encore de les plus structurées
et qui avait une mentalité qui était
beaucoup plus âgées notre kiosque sans
plus d'arriver en 2012 des milliers de
combattants étrangers convergent vers la
syrie on sera content ya vraiment une
myriade de d'acteurs présents sur le
banc mjc jeanrenaud fini par collaborer
ça a aidé
et à l'époque que ce soit l'armée
syrienne libre ou d'autres groupes
plusieurs collabore avec chabab al nassr
à bonne fin janvier 2013 c'est ici que
la police croit que deux chemins se
croisent l'histoire de deux otages
américains et celle de combattants
pourquoi être des canadiens
les combattants viennent chercher
matthew dans sa cellule ils sont masqués
armés de grenades et portent chacun deux
fusils d'entre eux m'a dit dans un très
bon anglais
comment va-t-il j'ai répondu ma famille
me manquait
[Musique]
ils m'ont donné un morceau de papier
m'ont demandé d'écrire tous mes mots de
passe les codes d'accès ils ont avec eux
un ordinateur portable
ils forcent mathiot à accéder à ces
quand
celui l'ordinateur était grassouillet ou
l'appliance shops nous autres avaient
les yeux tombants est un peu de route
dans la barde
trois jours plus tard matthew météo
mettent de côté leurs désaccords et
essais pour une première fois de
s'échapper rapidement ils sont repérés
et les conséquences seront graves
[Musique]
j'avais des genoux pliés dans un pneu
est retenu par une barre de fer pour que
je ne puisse pas bougé les pieds
il vous tourner sur le dos les pieds
dans les airs ils prennent un cam l'épée
comme ça ils vous frappent avec le câble
ensuite ils seront placés dans le coffre
d'une voiture est amené à l'institut
électrique ride and au noir est d'alep
pendant deux semaines ils sont privés de
nourriture bas dessus reçoivent des
impulsions électriques et sont forcés à
boire de l'eau contaminée le 16 février
mathieu rencontre de nouveau les hommes
masqués les hommes rap ou six visites à
théo pour une première fois le pont ce
tout de suite que l accent anglophone
qu'indien un autre accent francophone
gad théaux a grandi dans l'état du
vermont à la frontière québécoise
je vais passer du temps à montréal
j'avais même un important moment là bas
je connais l'accent québécois
j'adore leur théo se rappelle avoir été
interrogés par le plus corpulents des
deux celui qu'il croit être un québécois
je dois avec lui que j'ai causé le plus
c'était sympa ce n'était pas un gars
méchant j'ai encore car j'étais gentil
et j'aurais dû j'ai faim ils m'ont donné
à manger j'ai une matraque sans raison
pour rien ils n'ont pas à faire ça
c'étaient des enfants c'est canadienne
rien à voir avec les britanniques qui
coupait la tête à tout le monde
les canadiennes les plus doux idéaliste
n'ont pas levé un petit doigt sur moi
contrairement à mathew tait au n'avait
pas de carte de crédit donc pas d'argent
volé la première question était comment
vous vous sentez à ce que tout se passe
bien comme ça est-ce que j'aurais dit
non il nous tu ne vas pas sonné matra
qui pour rien on a faim on a besoin des
deux c'est une tragédie ma famille n'a
rien entendu de man depuis des mois je
voulais qu'ils sachent que j'avais
besoin de leur aide
théo aimerait bien leur parler de
montréal de cette ville qu'ils ont un
com mais il craint les représailles
je n'ai pas que eux ils sachent que moi
je savais quelque chose sur un parce que
j'avais peur qu'il ay 10 à 8 c'est trop
et je veux pas encourager leurs
sensations de menaces jouer que et se
sentent en sécurité envers moi un
interrogatoire à l'autre bout du monde
par des hommes que théo quoi être des
canadiens ou des québécois dans cette
importante histoire d'enlèvement par
al-qaïda de deux american séries
c'est un échange qui n'auraient
peut-être jamais été portée à
l'attention des autorités canadiennes
sauf pour cette erreur les cartes de
crédit de match où ils ont été utilisés
pour acheter divers objets des bottes
des montres et même libre format de
poche du kama sutra la majorité de la
marchandise est envoyé à des adresses de
rien ni de qui laisse en turquie et en
indonésie
sauf pour deux colis envoyés à une
adresse ici à montréal
[Musique]
d'alep en syrie à un appartement de wes
mans au coeur de la ville de montréal
deux paquets qui soulève beaucoup de
questions le 13 février 2013
la carte de crédit de match ou ailleurs
est utilisé pour commander plusieurs
appareils électroniques dont une caméra
vidéo
la commande est annulée mais peu de
temps après deux tablettes de marque
samsung sont envoyés à la même adresse
le destinataire est un autre jeune de 19
ans qui s'exerçait au centre de tir mais
en février 2013
il n'a pas encore quitté pays
selon nos informations d'autres paquets
aurait pu être livrée dans la région de
montréal un bon de commande a été
enregistrée pour un envoi à laval nous
ne savons pas si la commande a été
complétée mais fait intéressant la
commande est adressé au petit frère d'un
des dix qui se sont entraînés au centre
de thil
le petit frère faisait aussi partie du
groupe centre de tir mais il n'aurait
jamais quitté pour la syrie
mais qu'est ce que ça vous dit que
paquet soit arrivé à une adresse ainsi
certainement bizarre je pensais que je
pense que c'était même le jour même où
une nous enterre un tre interrogé
il entend passer les commandes sur
internet je pense que le seul lien
qu'ils ont c'est vraiment laid les
achats en ligne qui ont été faits qui
ont été envoyés à l'adresse à montréal
et l'accent québécois la ouais mais
c'est parce que c'est comme peu probable
moi si j'avais un truc comme ça j'aurais
pas envoyer des choses chez nous menacer
c'est pas très intelligent en commun
comme scénario
donc il ya peut-être quelqu'un qui a un
intérêt dans le fond à leur faire porter
le chapeau aussi
[Musique]
confronté par la sib ici l'an dernier le
jeune de wesmount refuse de donner plus
d'explications sur les colis près d'un
mois plus tard en mars 2013
mathieu et théo de retour à l'hôpital
pour enfants d'alep rencontre de nouveau
le des canadiens celui qu'il croit être
un québécois ce lui qui était le chef
opérateur d'un d'une caméra vidéo
théo nous explique que les geôliers
enregistre des vidéos
les otages sont vêtus de combinaisons
orange et sont forcés de faire de
fausses confessions de le dire je suis
venu j'ai été envoyé par la cia
si je suis jaloux et pas le gars qui
était responsable de la torture dans la
prison était à deux mètres
donc c'était évident lui il savait le
maquis me poser des questions le
canadien savais que je devais à demain
il savait aussi qu'ils étaient où vous
voulez contacter sa famille mais ils ont
refusé de l'aider
j'aurais donné mon la bracine même de ma
mère m'aime ils ont fait il aurait pu
nous aider ils auraient pu aider au
moins ma famille il savait qu'on était
sans espoir j'étais en est issu strass
on avait faim il aurait pu faire quelque
chose et ils ont préféré de volée il
était concentré sur ça le vol
dans les jours suivants le jeune de
westmount prend l'avion de montréal pour
se rendre en turquie
il traverse par la suite en syrie selon
nos sources
wasyl boga doudou aurait payé son billet
les deux tablettes samsung ht avec la
carte de crédit de matthew aboutissent
toujours selon nos sources dans les
mains de wassim
des jeunes qui se sont entraînés au
centre de tir ils sont maintenant six à
avoir foulé le sol syrien
une fois que les jeunes sont partis se
retrouvent en syrie est ce que l'on perd
leur trace complètement où il ya une
façon de les surveiller
on n'a pas de service de l'enseignement
avec serge agit sur le territoire
canadien
on a pas de signal vous avez quand même
une certaine je t'avais mais là on n'y
dépanneur de docteur max à 100 de nos
frontières ce complexe encore plus
complexe si les suspects sont tous des
amis
ça complique beaucoup la requête parce
que quand vous avez déjà qu'ils se
connaissent entre eux sera réseau
confiance qui est difficile à briser
puis si par exemple les femmes
d'infiltration lors c'est pénétrer dans
les réseaux l'a oublié de balle à mars
jaba annoncera ne figure pas encore sur
la liste canadienne des groupes
terroristes et en faire partie n'est pas
un acte terroriste en soi mais sur une
personne participe à l'enlèvement ou
l'extorsion d'un leurs prisonniers
est-ce considéré comme un acte
terroriste si on regarde les critères de
définition qui étaient en vie on rentre
la non motivation politique on veut
essayer de faire des pressions sur 20
nos organisations tierces menace
d'utilisation d'aberrations de
motivation politique et religieuse on
est là non mais que s'est il vraiment
passé en syrie j'avais l'impression que
s'ils traversaient que l'or c'était
vraiment fini qui mettrait sa vie en
danger pic puisqu'elle fait pas de
retour en arrière aussi qu'ils
commettraient peut-être des gestes
irréparables
fin juillet 2013 matthew était aux
essais une deuxième fois de s'évader
matthew avait remarqué que les montants
du châssis n'était pas bien soudée
surface il détaché les montants du
châssis pour les plier
je pourrais m'offrir un tel plan théo
devait aider matthew à sortir en premier
ou en sucre comme superman j'ai sorti
mes bras j'ai rentré mon ventre puis je
suis resté coincé à la taille à cause de
mon pantalon
je les détacher je me suis glissé à
l'intérieur et ensuite matthew devait
tirer théo par la fenêtre n'était pas
une opération qu'on pouvait faire soi
même donc plus il est sorti il a essayé
pendant quelques secondes de me tirer à
travers la fenêtre
j'étais coincé mais il fallait
travailler un peu il a paniqué puis est
parti
[Musique]
la tiu s'enfuit dans les rues d'alep et
trouve un jeune homme qu'il aidera à
sortir du pays
théo restera seul derrière et cette fois
ci la punition va au delà de la torture
[Musique]
montaner dans le désert ils m'ont
menotté dans les six semaines à venir où
après suivant j'avais les mains
menottées
j'avais les bras les jambes liées et
j'avais les uns les yeux bandés
théo n'est pas au bout de ses peines
il devra attendre encore un an avant
d'être libéré une longue attente qui lui
permettra de se rapprocher de ses
ravisseurs étaient 2013
la plupart des jeunes québécois
reviennent au pays
les du jeune 19 ans sont de retour
depuis juillet le jeune de 24 ans parti
avec son passeport tunisien les suit en
septembre
depuis son retour il suit de près tous
les procès impliquant des montréalais
accusés d'actes terroristes à plusieurs
reprises
nous leur avons demandé de nous accorder
une entrevue formel ce qu'ils ont
toujours refusé de faire
sauf celui de 24 ans qui nous a écrit
ceci je réitère que je n'ai rien à voir
aux crimes qui ont été commis contre
choix yeux et pas de noces je trouve
donc injuste d'associer mon visage à
cela juste à cause du stand de tir où il
n'était nullement question de rejoindre
un groupe terroriste ou commettre un
crime
les deux amis de 19 ans sont maintenant
mariés ont de jeunes enfants et essaie
de refaire leur vie
ils ont depuis leur tour adopté le
soufisme une branche pacifiste de
l'islam le soufisme certainement une
porte salvatrice pour des gens qui sont
en phase de radicalisation
parce qu'il a une approche beaucoup plus
spirituelle l'imam omar koné connaît
bien ces deux jeunes depuis leur retour
on a une conversation simple où
effectivement l'un d'entre eux m'a dit
nous étions requête nous avons été mal
d'idées au départ nous avons découvert
la vérité nous en sommes très désolés et
aujourd'hui
nous demandons à vivre comme des
citoyens honorables et nous accomplir et
à servir servir des gens qui sont autour
de nous ils sont plus des victimes
qu'autre chose ces jeunes
victimes qui sont partis je pense avec
une bonne intention pour faire leur
devoir de musulman
[Musique]
mais je pense qu'ils ont été manipulés
dans le groupe parce qu'il ya un homme
vous perceviez comme plus radicaux
justement où ben c'est sûr que là qui
étaient beaucoup plus radicaux un autre
sont encore là bas qui sont restés là
bas pays qui reviendront pas non plus
selon nos sources wassim et tarek
voyagerait toujours entre la syrie et la
turquie
wassim s'est radicalisée et aurait passé
du temps avec l'état islamique
impossible de les rejoindre pour avoir
leurs commentaires ou à simon verrait
des vidéos de menaces du moyen orient à
certains des jeunes qui sont revenus à
montréal nous disent nos sources les
abus l'ancien beau frère de wassim
ismaël habib a d'ailleurs reçu plusieurs
menaces
ismaël habib a fait partie des dix qui
se sont entraînés au centre de tir mais
il n'est pas parti pour la turquie avant
l'été 2013
il subit présentement son procès à
montréal
il est accusé d'avoir tenté de quitter
le canada pour rejoindre un groupe
terroriste et d'avoir fait une fausse
déclaration dans le but d'obtenir un
passeport faire pendant que certains des
jeunes rentrent au pays
théophane ans est toujours sous le joug
de ses ravisseurs
mais plus les jours passent plus des
liens se tissent entre le prisonnier et
ses geôliers 18 ans parce que vous vous
êtes mariés non séparés
et lui fournissent même du papier et des
crayons confiné dans sa cellule
théo entame la rédaction de son roman
est choisi chaque mots soigneusement
sachant que ses ravisseurs vont scruter
ses écrits sa part d'une société qui
bouleversée par un mouvement religieux
par des fanatiques quoi donc sa mémé
l'histoire se déroule ici dans le
vermont mais ça parle j prix les
dialogues j'ai pris les mots je suis
pris eux les tensions les émotions de ce
qui se passait autour de moi dans
l'instant présent
théo terminera son roman au vermont
après de longues négociations il est
finalement libéré au mois d'août
théo pourra enfin revoir sa famille aux
etats unis des sceaux marylise on sunday
et babette
[Musique]
il y a deux ans les policiers canadiens
ont rencontré les deux otages aux états
unis pour recueillir leur version des
faits et leur montrer des photos de
suspects mais leurs ravisseurs portaient
des cagoules donc impossible
d'identifier qui que ce soit je ne peux
pas eu grand duché aucune personne nous
avons aussi montré des photos des jeunes
suspects étaient au il n'a pas pu
reconnaître personne
quand je vois le type de joueur est ce
l'oeuvre ces jeux ouais non pas 9 le nez
mais quand nous lui avons montré la
confrontation entre adrien arsenault de
la sib ici et le jeune de wesmount qui
aurait reçu les deux tablettes quelque
chose attire son attention
interrogé le maire en droite
oui alors quand j'ai vu ça je me suis
dit l intérêt interrogé l'autre type
mais à gauche pour pourquoi vous dites
ça passe un vilain
la forme son corps sa taille son gabarit
c'est donc ça pourrait être celui qui
lie m'interroger le l'enquêteur
principal quoi celui qui était
francophone
oui ça pourrait introduit ne peut pas
aller au delà de ça à l'été 2015
la grc effectué des perquisitions aux
résidences de wassim boughadou de tahar
ex aker et aux résidences des deux
jeunes de 19 ans selon nos sources le
groupe centre de tir est soupçonné entre
autres d' acte terroriste liée à
l'enlèvement et à l'extorsion de théo
panos et de match ou ailleurs mais dans
le dossier des deux otages
la grc n'a porté aucune accusation à ce
jour contre les jeunes du centre de tir
et nous n'avons pas de preuves que des
jeunes se trouvaient dans la pièce avec
les otages moi je trouve que c'est de
l'acharnement
c'est de l'acharnement et ont pour
beaucoup ce qu'ils on lance c'est
vraiment ténue comme preuves et il
s'accroche à ça mais je pense qu'à la
fin lyon
ils pourront pour y éprouver une
étiquette de terroriste est très
difficile à effacer
elle ne vous suis pas simplement dans
vos applications sociales mais dans
votre entourage ou dans vos amis ou dans
le travail que vous faites et il est
certain que les humains font des erreurs
font toujours aiguilles et d'une façon
ou d'une autre on a tous lu un âge où un
autre de mauvaises influences et il est
important de pouvoir revenir mais l'anc
est toujours active bien jeter une ombre
dans la vie quotidienne de ces jeunes
adultes
[Musique]
un jeune homme membre d'un groupe
soupçonné d'actes terroristes a pu
prendre un autoportrait avec le premier
ministre
sans ce fait bon exemple c'est le tollé
cris quand l'auto portrait de des jeunes
de 19 ans avec le premier ministre
justin trudeau a été publiée dans les
médias il y a quelques semaines même si
son identité n'a pas été révélée
plusieurs dont théo se demande comment
une personne sous enquête pour des actes
terroristes peut approcher le premier
ministre ils ont commis une petite
erreur même une erreur assez grave de
laisser approcher au premier ministre un
gars qui est soupçonné d'avoir participé
dans le djihad en syrie ça c'est grave
je trouve il n'aurait pas dû faire ça
monsieur trudeau m
être proche des gens sochalien
complexifie beaucoup beaucoup le travail
plus vous pouvez pas contrôler
exactement qui est dans la la foule qui
va se pointer une photo d'un premier
ministre donc parce que là c'est du bon
jugement de garde du corps est ce que
cette personne ne semble agressive
cathala barça ce qu'elle est le problème
puis mon voile et ses allées où paul
donc c'est sûr que de produits images
c'est un problème mais prévenir ce genre
de situation là presque quatre ans après
leur rencontre avec les hommes qu'ils
croient être des qualités et où et
matthew attendent toujours que justice
soit faite
j'aimerais bien que il se livra au
système canadien qu'ils avouent tous
qu'ils disent ce qu'ils ont fait en
syrie et qui soit aux notes un coma mais
le public et système judiciaire chez
vous j'aimerais bien que les autorités
canadiennes prouvent qu'elles ne sont
pas la merci du fbi a fait quelque chose
vous avez l'épreuve la documentation
le gars est dans votre pays l'ajc les
proches des jeunes soit maintenant la
fin de ce cauchemar et espère retrouver
une vie plus paisible
je me souhaite capable qu'on soit
capable de dire ben oui de prouver
qu'ils rien à voir latin puis qu'on soit
capable finalement de tourner la page
puis bossert autre chose habillé de la
difficulté à tourner la page avant la
guerre quand j'écoutais la musique
populaire syrienne j'écoute j'écoutais
souvent cette musique c'est une chanson
qui parle de la violence qui a et venir
cette musique résonne toujours dans la
chaumière de théo au vermont elle lui
rappelle que malgré ses 22 mois de
captivité sa quête de faire connaître la
situation en syrie est toujours bien
présente
c'est un travail d'une vie en fait de
donner la preuve de on est on est
capable de comprendre un pays étranger
c'est le travail d'une vie mais je
continue c'est mon travail c'est ce que
je suis en train de poursuivre actionné
[Musique]
j'ai changé de monde pense au final